this Friday PFT p.m. continuing from the
PFT barn we're joined now by the general
manager of the Chicago Bears he is Ryan
pace Ryan welcome back how are you pal
I'm good Mike how you been hey I've been
doing well it's been a crazy few months
we adapt we adjust we move forward and
I'm curious especially for someone in
your position now that the draft is over
you don't have the the roster turn that
we normally would see when you have the
benefit of bringing players in having
them on the field seeing who's working
out seeing who's not who gets injured
who doesn't how different is your job in
the month of May late May then it would
have been in any other year that's a
good question Mike because I think this
time of year it's always exciting
because it's kind of like opening up
your presents you're getting to see
these players perform on the practice
field so I think there's been a little
more time now devoted to sitting in on a
lot of the objects of the defence
meetings the virtual meetings you know
coach now he's done a good job bringing
in guest speakers listening in to those
guys so I think it's been good just to
kind of jump in with the X's and O's of
our football team and just see and it's
good to see how engaged our players are
at this time period but from the
standpoint of getting on the field and
who knows when that's going to be well
what kind of plans are you making to
accelerate the missed time that
especially the younger players are going
to have the draft picks the undrafted
free agent getting them up to speed
without the benefit of that that
opportunity in the offseason whether
it's the rookie minicamp
the OTAs the mandatory minicamp all
those different things you ordinarily
would have how do you get guys to make
up for lost time and get ready for week
one it's it's a big time challenge and I
think that's where our coaches and our
players have stepped up I mean our
attendance has been a hundred percent
everybody's been engaged and locked in
but like you're right for the young
players it's hard because nothing
substitutes being on the field but those
guys have locked in they're doing the
best they can with it the cards they're
dealt and you know I think our coaches
are being creative too because it's hard
to stay engaged in these virtual media
all the time so I think you know Matt's
been changing it up making it fun doing
some creative things to keep those guys
engaged and learning along the way I
think some of our veteran players have
done a good job too it's kind of taking
those guys under their wing because they
can they could hit these guys from a
different perspective than our coach
just came a lot of ways so it's it's
really a collective effort but it's a
big time challenge
you mentioned coach naggy using speakers
through the technology we've all been
embracing during the pandemic give me
the one that surprised you the most from
the standpoint of the power of the
message the content and the message
relative to what was coming from Oh
so we had we've had probably almost 20
of them you know so what's interesting
to me Mike is uh without naming specific
names because is is the common
denominators amongst a lot of these guys
you're talking about Hall of Famers from
all different forms and it usually comes
down to their passion and love for the
game I mean there's a borderline
obsession almost maniacal approach to
how obsessed they are would be great the
passion for the game their football IQ
and all these guys have been off the
charts their process so it's just so
good for our younger players and our
veterans to hear that from all these
guys guys that have been in their shoes
and what they did to become great
players and the sacrifices they made
it's good for all of us to hear it's
been inspiring along the way you know
you got your career started for a long
period of time with the New Orleans
Saints and that was a franchise that
didn't have much of a history when you
joined it in 2001
not many playoff appearances I think
maybe one postseason win right before
you joined in 2001 and then you become
the general manager one of those storied
franchises in all of football and you
know we're in Chicago in September and I
was saying earlier today how blown away
I was by the city by Soldier Field by
the fan support by the atmosphere by
just that sense of history what kind of
a birdie does that place on you do you
feel that when you have that job as the
general manager of a team that is one of
the most iconic and historic franchises
in all of football
I think I think you definitely feel it
we all feel it and I wouldn't want it
any other way I mean that's one of the
reasons why you accept a challenge like
this and you know it is a challenge when
these jobs become available and you've
said it going into the nineteenth season
the excitement was off the charts
because of what we did the previous year
twelve and four winning the division so
you go through last year and it's and it
just eats at you and we all have a bad
taste in her mouth
eight eight definitely isn't good enough
we didn't fulfill our expectations so
now it's been about everybody you know
don't be defensive everybody drop
through he goes we're all humble what
can we do better to get this thing back
on the track that it was on 18 and I
think we've done a lot a lot of things
this offseason to get that going because
last year was unacceptable hey you know
I didn't enter into this conversation
with the plan of dragging you through
the mud of 2019 even treat me by that
juxtaposition of what happened in 2018
twelve and four so close to winning a
wild card game against the Eagles the
expectations were a lot higher last year
as you personally deconstruct what
happened in 2019 have you picked up any
trench any clues any signs any trends
it's just a bad play here or there a bad
game here there I mean what is it that
you can see from last season that maybe
can help the organization avoid that
happening the next time you enter a year
with high expectations and reason to
have high expectations yeah Mike I don't
think like in any season it's never one
thing it's a plethora of things and we
can go through you know it starts with
personnel starts with me there's some
tweaks we made in that area we had a lot
of unfortunate injuries last year I know
Akeem going down
I bet really hurt us on defense so
there's a number of things but I think
you know Matt and I talked about details
details from every area of our building
just locking into the details I think
you know that was a factor um but again
I think some of the some of the
personnel changes we've made some of the
coaching changes we've made staying
healthy as a team changing some of our
processes is that's all been part of the
kind of as we deconstructed last year
and figure out what happened it wasn't
just one thing Mike it was a it was a
number of things but what I like doing
with Matt is as soon as the season ends
we
look at ourselves and hey what can we do
better but we're both very open with
that we're both very honest with that
and I think it's just been a process to
get to this point right now and that's
the one hard part about not all being
together right now is I think our teams
in a good state of mind
I think everybody's a little pissed off
everybody has a chip on their shoulder
and I would love to be carrying that
momentum through the OTAs and through
the mini camps unfortunately we don't
have that we're gonna have to pick that
up in training camp Lynette when that
starts because I do feel like our team
isn't the right mindset right now I take
you back to 2005 that was the season of
the hurricane in New Orleans now it
didn't disrupt any of the offseason
preparation it was something that
impacted the organization the city to
stay at the entire region in late August
but is there anything that you've taken
from that experience even though it was
15 years ago to maybe help plan for how
unpredictable this season may be whether
it's training camp on the road whether
it's gauged without fans whether it's a
week or two of the season it's shut down
whether it's maybe having to play the
game the home game home game in some
other stadium how much of what you went
through personally in 2005 can help you
plan for and help you plan the
organization for what could come this
season and I think a lot of those
experiences and you don't even realize
it when it's happening at the moment is
that there's no excuses in our league
you just seen that happen in New Orleans
during Katrina it happened really every
time a hurricane came towards that city
we quickly adapted and what I when I
fell from the leadership there with
Shaun and Mickey is there was never
gonna an excuse it was let's adapt and
let's adjust and and that's what we did
and in from 2005 to 2006 I mean that was
a major shift in that team under trying
times
um but you bring in the right people um
things can change quickly in our league
and we saw it in coaching Aggies first
year in 2018 of Chicago Mike how quick
that shifted and the momentum we carried
and the confidence and the swag the team
play with and we got to regain that I
mean it's still there we still have all
the same core pieces again some some
tweaks here and there some tweaks to the
coaching staff but that's where that's
what I say I like where Artie
right now or like what the mindset of
our team is right now and I'm exciting
once we started once we start can
because I can feel that momentum you
were with the Saints several seasons
before Sean Payton arrived is the coach
and then you were there for nearly a
decade with him as the head coach what's
something you picked up from him that
you kind of still carry with you today
when it comes to team building team
preparation just what it takes to win in
the NFL yeah I think first of all very
he's very aggressive so he's not afraid
he's you know he's not afraid to make
hard decisions you know he's he's
decisive and Mickey's the same way
aggressive and decisive with those
decisions no regrets never looked back
not afraid to think outside the box but
also very conscious of the culture of
that team and I think anytime you drift
away from that and it's easy to do Mike
and it's an enticing to do but usually
when you do that once you realize you've
done that and you've affected the locker
room the damage is already done by the
time you try to correct yourself for
beliefs a player the damage is already
done in the locker room so I think it's
it's being aggressive with the moves you
make now looking back off pregnant with
decisiveness but then being very
conscious of the culture in or locker
room because it's a fine line I mean
twelve and four to eight and eight it's
a fine line that I think that I think
it's because the people the staff and
the players you have in your building
being conscious of that one thing I've
gleaned from studying Sean Payton over
the years is that he never compounds a
mistake trying to justify it if you make
a mistake you acknowledge it and you
move on even if in a roundabout way it
makes you look bad by admitting the
mistake it makes you look a lot worse if
you double down on the mistake because
once you realize you need to go in a
different direction that's where you go
is that something that fuels you that
willingness to say hey you know what
maybe we didn't do this right we've got
to move on instead of sticking with a
plan that that clearly isn't work 100% I
think you know Matt Matt has that same
blueprint from coach Reid and I think
it's you know I think it but comes from
humility and doing what's best for the
team we used to always say that you know
when you're making hard decisions what's
best for the organization and not
letting your ego get in a way because
hey this was this was your idea are you
selected miss player whatever it is
what's best for the team and sometimes
those are hard decisions when you have
to remove emotions um but I think when
you when you do that you're thinking of
what's best for the entire organization
when you make those decisions and for me
to be honest like that
I think that's come pretty natural and
pretty easy and you're probably right
it's probably because of my experience
in New Orleans well and I mention that
because obviously the biggest topic
involving the Bears the short-term and
long-term future of quarterback Mitch
drew Biscay the second pick in the 2017
draft and I know you've certainly been
asked these questions in other settings
but I'm just curious to have this
conversation as it relates to ultimately
why the decision was made to not pick up
that fifth year option while this is
still a guy who is very much in the
plans and potentially could be your
starting quarterback wired a wire in
2020 for sure you know when we looked at
the fifth-year option it was it was it
was a date that we had to make a
decision on that move and we had plenty
of time to discuss and I have to make
that decision till after the draft so
there was a collective decision amongst
a lot of people and just because we
didn't exercise a fifth-year option
doesn't mean that we don't believe in
Mitch I mean we did the same thing with
Kyle fuller a couple years ago and it
worked out really well for him so mitch
is in a position right now he knows that
Matt and I met with him and we were
transparent we were honest it's a
competition you know and I think I think
I like the way he's responded right now
he's really embraced the challenge he's
in a great spot and so it really doesn't
change anything for us you know let's we
got a lot of competition going on
throughout our roster I know the focus
is on the quarterback position but we
didn't expect him to embrace the
challenge I know Nick Foles is gonna
embrace the challenge and we'll do
what's best for the Bears
you know when I get asked about that
situation and it's very easy from my
perspective the fifth-year option 24
point eight million dollars the
transition tender for 2019 that becomes
the fifth year option since he was a
top-10 pick if if he ends up playing
extremely well this year and the
proverbial good problem to have arises
you have to use the franchise tank it's
not gonna be all that much more than
what the fifth year option would have
been anyway so you're rolling the
nice to an extent but again if the dice
come up that way he plays so well this
year they would use the franchise tag
then great great so be it we have a
quarterback that we can carry into the
future as a franchise guy potential Mike
we went over all those scenarios that
you're talking about best case worst
case back and forth plenty of dialogue
on that and we were very comfortable
with this decision and then it just came
down to hey communicating with Mitch
being honest and being transparent like
we always are and that's when I love the
way he approached it I mean I think once
he digested it you simply kind of seemed
clinched his jaw and embrace and hey
let's go let's go and I think it's gonna
be fun to see this play out and again
both of those guys I know it's it's been
virtual meetings but but Mitch and Nick
have been awesome those meetings
completely engaged competition really
can't start till we start rolling a
training camp but you really like the
mindset of both those players they both
come in obviously with a lot of
knowledge of the offense just from their
their history so they kind of have a leg
up in the times that we're dealing with
right now which has been good but I love
the way they both embraced it it's been
a it's been very healthy
it's a strange here to have an open
competition a quarterback when you can't
get onto the field what will the
timetable be once it's time to get out
there have practices split up reps
when will the goal be to make that
decision as to who the guy is to start
the season yeah we haven't said this
this is gonna be the timetable we just
said hey look it's gonna be a daily
evaluation for us you know and obviously
there's a little bit of acceleration to
it you know Matt and I have already
talked about you know playing our
players more on the preseason this year
we hadn't done that as much the past two
years so that's gonna be important to
get the starters out there for we got
kombu there's probably about four
different position battles I can think
of throughout a roster and I know
quarterbacks the focus but there's a
couple other important ones as well so I
think plan our starters for the
preseason is going to be important to
see that we're hopeful we can have
combined practices with the Denver
Broncos I don't know if that's gonna
happen we're hopefully had our fingers
crossed on that um but all those moments
are going to be valuable for us to
really evaluate that competition
of other words just on the same page
give me the other position battles that
you regard is important going into camp
you know I think I think we got someone
on the offensive line specifically right
guard there's there's there's one at
safety with Bush and gifts in the right
corner spot you know we drafted a corner
and Jalen Johnson who signed Artie burns
we have Kevin Tolliver who's been on
their team so all of it's a blind corner
safety quarterback those are definitely
competitions for us as we look into this
training camp Nick Foles is one of the
most enigmatic players I've ever
encountered me announce now one thing we
know for sure he will always be the
consummate teammate if he ends up being
the backup quarterback he will support
the starter and every way possible he
won't complain he won't mopey we'll be
all in for the role that he's given but
if he's on the field we've seen the ups
and the downs and the highs and the lows
and what made you and coach Nagy
confident that the Nick Foles you get
will be closer to the guy who was the
Super Bowl MVP a couple of years ago
with Philadelphia and not the guy with
the Rams that look like the fastball was
gone and along with every other pitch in
his tool bag yeah so we have four
coaches on her staff that have worked
with Nick and coached Nick at different
places which I think is valuable because
they've seen him at different stages of
his career so when you're evaluating the
position obviously the film and what you
see on field you know is important part
of the product but I think the knowledge
Mike that we know of Nick behind the
scenes how he deals with adversity
what kind of teammate he is all the
things that you mentioned at the start
on that that was huge for us to have
that intimate knowledge with coaches on
our staff um and I think we went through
the different styles of offenses that
he's played in what we do here in
Chicago is very similar what he was
doing in Philadelphia with coach
Peterson so I think there's a lot of
common ah not commonalities there so I
think that style of play you saw in
Philly with Nick um and we saw it
firsthand in the playoffs I think is
something that you could expect to see
in Chicago a couple of other topics
unrelated to the Bears
but of interest this week with the
virtual ownership meetings the fourth
and 15 alternative to the onside kick
it's been tabled the impression I've
gotten is that positions are mixed and
split on whether or not to pivot to that
as the alternative the onside kick
what's your position on whether or not
that's within 15 play should be
available and I guess my understanding
is it would be twice per game per team
to use that if they so choose yeah I
wasn't surprised Mike when it got tabled
you could tell just the feeling around
the league that everybody was split on
this one everybody was having a hard
time with it I'm typically normally kind
of a traditionalist when it comes to
these things but with this one it's
intriguing I like the excitement of it I
think we always we've got to be looking
at ways to develop our game and enhance
our game so this is one of those ones I
think when you first hear it being a
little bit more traditional I said I
don't know but the more you dug into it
it's very interesting it's exciting um
and it's it's something that I think
we'd be interested in seeing go through
but I understand what I got table I know
there will be a lot more discussion on
it as we go forward see sometimes when
things get tabled they they just kind of
go away and never come back do you think
this is something that will resurface
next year I definitely do because I
think there's a lot of strong opinions
on it and just talking to other GM's and
head coaches around the league I think
this is something that's intriguing
again it adds a lot of excitement to our
game I think it was a good idea this is
something I think I think we just even
more time to discuss it make sure
everybody gets comfortable with it
because it is a little outside the box
um but but I think it's definitely gonna
be something that's gonna circle back
around last one what do you think of the
current sky judge experiment I know the
league doesn't use that term I'm not
sure what team to use term to use excuse
me it's like an enhancement of the
current replay assistant role activated
by the referee not by anyone else a
limited number of plays that can be
reviewed and again it's experimental
only to the preseason what's your gut
tell you as to whether this is going to
go anywhere in 2020 or beyond yeah I
think did my personal opinion mike is
and I think I saw this quote John Perry
said this recently we
don't have a safety net to fix a
game-changing egregious missed call and
I think at some point we're gonna in
some facet we're gonna have to protect
ourselves for that because we don't we
don't have that right now and and nobody
wants that and you know we saw it you
know firsthand with the Saints and the
Rams and and I think at some point we're
just gonna you need a way to change to
fix a game-changing egregious mistake um
so I know that's another one of those
things that's kind of been tabled a
little bit and to be honest I think
right now a lot of our focus is
understandably on getting our players
and staff back in the facility so I
think this year more than ever some of
these rural tweaks and proposals kind of
get pushed a little bit on the back
burner not that they should but I think
our focus is a little elsewhere right
now but I think eventually I'm in favor
of that I think I think it's that it's
inevitable it's in some facet something
like that will happen I think we're on
the same page on that the idea that you
need to have that what I call break
glass and event of emergency option
where there is something that everyone
recognizes this is a problem it needs to
be fixed and we need to have a mechanism
for doing it now but where's that line
and I think we learned that laughing
with pass interference replay review
it's one thing to say if a guy gets
wiped out if the ball is coming in yeah
obviously in pass interference but then
you get to the closer content and the
tug of the Jersey in the pull of the arm
well is that something that is worthy of
the emergency option or do you just let
it go and I think that's going to be the
challenge for whatever the topic is
under the rules where's the line between
egregious and not agrees yeah I think
that's just gonna take time and
experience for us to smooth oil it out
well Ryan
I appreciate some of your time I'll let
you get back to your Friday afternoon we
congratulate you on your success great
career so far
it was a great 2018 it's always good
when the Bears are a playoff team and we
hope that that happens again for you
very soon all right thanks buddy
nice talking all right take care of same
here
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports